wir haben eine situation am ende
tatsächlich das auslassen
so werden wir die hinter sich stationen
folgen und lassen die intensivstation
mit kubicas können
das ist auch keine verheißung das würde
übersetzt bedeuten uns sterben pro tag
ungefähr tausende menschen
was bedeutet das und er will das
riskieren wenn wir das zulassen also
wenn ich wirkend sage wir haben noch auf
der intensivstation
ich lasse jetzt zu viele reihen wie die
den besitzern versorgen kann jeder
zweite stirbt erwartet werden muss auch
bei diesen jugend b 1 1 -sieg und
verläuft erklärt schädigt die lunge sehr
viel schwerer und daher wenig dass 1000
todesfälle bekannt aus seiner ersten
1000 durch schneller aber die intensive
passiert wie etwa kapazität waren
überlastet
ich darf es gar nicht so weit kommen
lassen wir haben eine neue mutation wenn
diese mutation nicht bekommen hätten wir
jetzt das gröbste hinter uns und wir
tatsächlich jetzt bestehende lockdown
erfolgreich genug gewesen um das ganze
so einzuschränken dass wir es bis zu
eben vom durchschlagen hätten
jetzt haben wir über diese gefährliche
mutation b 187 und das ist tatsächlich
bisher keinem land gelungen diese also
schnell viel schneller akademie mit
dieser mutation in den griff zu bekommen
oder dass es ausgangs beschränkungen in
dem loch raum gegeben etwas es gibt
keinen gegenbeispiel wo es gelungen wäre
ohne wir sind bild und wir liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren